I'll never forget coming out of therapy
and this guy was like Terry you have to
learn how to tell people no because I
was a pleaser and so I remember being at
dinner and people be like can I get
autographed I'm like yeah and I would
sign autographs for an hour with my
family there my my wife was like Terry
we're here we can't even enjoy it yeah
but these are my fans these are the
people that pay our bills and then she's
like you can't tell them no just for an
hour I remember being in counseling and
the counselor asked me she said what if
a director told you to do something you
didn't want to do I said well I have to
do it she said no you know I said yes I
do she said no you don't Terry I said
well I'm an actor she said yeah but you
don't have to do everything the director
tells you to do I said yes I do because
I'm an actor and she's like no no you
don't she said Terry because you don't
have to do that I said but I would lose
my job she said we'll get another job I
said but I'm an actor she's a Terry
don't have to do what you don't want to
do hey it's Evan Carmichael and I make
these videos because in my first
business I struggled to believe in
myself I quit on my business partner and
the thing that saved me was watching the
successful stories of entrepreneurs they
gave me the inspiration to keep going as
well as the strategies of what to do and
quite honestly I still need their
stories and motivation today as well so
today let's live your best believe life
and learn how you can take control of
your life
enjoy
I didn't know
especially since I was such a pleaser it
was one of the things well yeah yeah and
I'll never forget this guy came up to me
say Hey man can I get an autograph and I
was gonna do it I was in practice I said
and I looked at him I said no
he said come on man come on man I said
no no no
I went crazy the guy was like dude relax
man
I was like shaking
it was the first time
I was exercising this no my no no
and I was shaking I got back in the car
and I said you guys I was going I
thought I was going crazy
I thought I was going crazy
but what I was doing was dissecting
and piecing and understanding who I was
and what made me tick
and it's so thorough and it got so
thorough to the point where I was like
oh that why do I feel angry
if someone says that or why am I why am
I insulted why
is it me or is it them and see and once
I started asking these questions I could
let it go
and I was like oh man that's got nothing
to do with me
what was before it was just you insulted
me you know I mean I can't count to you
how many family gatherings are ruined
how many you know theme park outings
I've crushed people in tears I'm going
back to the rule
because I just everything had to be
perfect
everything had to be the way it's
supposed to be and then you didn't do it
the way I wanted it was it was hot my
way of the highway rule number two is
take personal responsibility with Tom
bilyu what is it you've learned about
why personal responsibility is and I've
seen on this podcast it's like if I'm
going to be counseled for anything it's
probably there's a number of things but
my pursuit of like
being a champion for personal
responsibility is up there mogow that
sat here and said when he published his
book he he open sources it to 500 people
and he says he loses about I think it
was 10 of people they just click off the
document when they get to the personal
responsibility part they're just seem to
be inherently offended by it
why where is the truth what can be done
okay so this goes back to what we were
talking about earlier which is I just
know people are gonna uh just really
love this section uh but I can't help
myself I would lose respect for myself
if I didn't say this stuff I could see
myself one day not being on camera
anymore I can't ever see myself saying
something that I don't believe to be
true
so here it goes you have to have a
belief system that is both true and
optimistic
personal responsibility is true and
wildly optimistic and it is people's
belief system and the value system that
they Cobble together over a lifetime
that will lead them to reject that and
all I can say is reject it at your own
Peril for the following reason personal
responsibility is about remembering you
can do something and change and I I can
sum up personal responsibility in a
single quote by Kobe Bryant
booze don't block dunks
that's personal responsibility you can
get so good at something that no matter
how much people hate you the best
athletes in the world were paid millions
of dollars and trained to stop Kobe
Bryant from scoring and yet he scored 81
points in a single game
so you can get so good no matter how
much people hate you no matter how much
they're training and trying to defeat
you they can't
and that is the most exciting thing in
the world to me that wait you're saying
that I can get so good at something that
at least the vast majority of humanity
can't stop me there will always of
course I'm unfortunately I don't I don't
yet believe that I am Kobe Bryant in
anything that I care about so but that I
can get better than the vast majority of
humanity at something by dedicating my
time and energy to that thing that is so
cool that is so liberating it's changed
my life it's given me hope it got me up
off the floor it it in every possible
way it has changed my life it is the
thing that I rely on when I'm feeling my
most anxious I'm like I can get better
at this a word and then I remember
that's right like if I put time and
energy into this I can get better so
it's okay if I'm actually not good at
this if people are coming after me and
saying you're stupid you're seeing this
wrong I'm like maybe I really am like
maybe there's really something to learn
here
even with personal responsibility if
somebody shows me that taking personal
responsibility for my life is worse than
if I didn't I would change but in every
metric I have ever encountered and
including all the people that I've
introduced this idea to that have then
gone on to do something with it it has
made every single one of their lives
better to a person without exception and
so I'm just like I want people to win so
badly I'm wired to love other people
winning almost as much as I love winning
myself when I was six I threw an Easter
egg contest so that my sister would find
more eggs than I did because I knew it
meant more to her and I just was so
happy to see her win so like it just
that is innate I didn't do anything to
earn that I'm not an extra nice person
just for whatever reason I really enjoy
seeing other people win
and so dude when I'm giving these ideas
I'm like it will help you it will help
you you like I'm already doing it my
life is already a reflection of this and
it's true and optimistic just to bring
it all back around it is true and
optimistic and so I hope people embrace
it I know that some people don't because
they have a value system where they're
getting value out of being in a helpless
position
and that's heartbreaking because it's it
doesn't feel good at least it didn't
when I was there
I'm trying to think of the rebuttals
because I agree that having a bias to
optimism and personal responsibility has
solved can I give you the rebuttal
please so the rebuttal is that societal
energy and momentum really really matter
and that we are the shout and the echo
so even though if you
feel like you are a victim and that life
is out of your control and it's stacked
against you and there's nothing you can
do
when you are the recipient of legitimate
Injustice the world is going to Rally to
your side and be like yo you've been
wronged we celebrate you we love you we
Elevate you like this is just so crazy
it should never happen to you that will
feel awesome
and so you've been embraced and there is
a lot of cultural momentum around that
now the problem is that when you're by
yourself thinking about yourself you
feel disempowered and it does not feel
good and you're in a very dark place
which is a big reason why I think right
now that people are I mean suicide is
like depending on the age group it's
like the number one leading cause of
death like teenage boys I mean that's
nuts so clearly something going on so I
don't think people will feel good about
themselves when they're by themselves if
they adopt that value system but they
are getting huge emotional rewards from
the crowd now the crowd can't save them
again when they're by themselves but
to deny that to be embraced for
something like that feels good would be
foolish because it really does feel good
and I spent time there feeling sorry for
myself for a long time and when
somebody's like wow that really does
suck I was like yeah man that feels good
to be acknowledged and so I get it and I
want to acknowledge it too like it
really is when people have the deck
stacked against them that really sucks
that really sucks and they're I mean
look I've spent enough time in the inner
cities there are people with the deck
stacked way hard against them
but my thing is
you can actually get out and you how
about this you can make your life a
hundred times better no matter how bad
it is you can make it 100 times better
and that Joy seeing people do that is
everything it's everything for them it's
everything for me as somebody who just
likes to see people win and I don't see
that same 100x Improvement on people
that embrace
a different value system but just real
and there's a lot of momentum
is that unwillingness to accept that I
do also somewhat linked to people's own
self-esteem because when we admit
personal responsibility for some people
especially those that have a lower sort
of sense of self-worth maybe they see
that as evidence of their further
evidence of their own inadequacy
I'm going to bend it more to Identity so
you build your identity and I I have the
deck stacked against me for whatever
reason
and
when that becomes your identity
and you value yourself for that like I
have the deck stacked against me and I
stand strong in the face of this and you
know I can deal with these slings and
arrows or I fight back against them and
so I become like I'm really on a mission
to fight against this and all of that
becomes your identity so now you're you
have to give up personal responsibility
to embrace that and to fight for it
but
you get that right you get the tribe you
get the other people in that community
that feel the same
but what you've given up is really being
able to change and to acquire skills and
to become capable of more and so my
obsession is getting people to
understand skills have utility now if
skills have utility and they let you do
something better than other people you
can do things that other people can't do
that's a monetizable b there's something
hardwired in all of us to work hard to
get to gain skills that allow us to
serve the group right as a social animal
you have an imperative buried in your
brain there is no way to escape it to
contribute to the group
so if you Embrace personal
responsibility you're going to get all
these other kinds of rewards because
you'll be able to accumulate skill set
you will be able to dunk and people will
not be able to stop you right like that
becomes the reality that you live in
it's super intoxicating because going
back to this idea of why it matters to
make sure that you have a narrative that
is true because when it's true your
predictive machine of a brain can
actually predict how to change the world
to what you want it to be which I will
Define power as the ability to close
your eyes imagine a world better than
this open your eyes gain the skills you
need to make that world come true
that's power and to get that power you
have to acquire skills to acquire skills
you have to take responsibility to take
responsibility you have to reject being
in the victim category rule number three
is use spiritual practices to heal with
Gabby Bernstein why is healing so
important for everyone at all times to
be on that Journey
and how do we heal trauma
you know when it's invisible all right
go ahead with the big stuff so and it's
all big stuff here yeah and and we're
ready to go there you and I have been
talking about our own traumatic
experiences and in fact I want to
acknowledge that the first time I really
spoke publicly about remembering my own
childhood trauma was with you yeah
because you made me feel safe enough to
do it
I where do I begin so we run from these
impermissible feelings from our past
these are emotional disturbances from
our childhood traumatic events trauma
with a big T trauma with a small t a big
T trauma is being sexually abused as a
child having some kind of violence
living through a catastrophic event
growing up in an alcoholic home a small
T traumas being bullied yeah uh small T
trauma is being told you're stupid by a
teacher small T trauma could be living
and surviving covid um
we've all lived through trauma way
before covid it's just now more present
for us but the traumatic events from our
past are the ones that are so
impermissible because inside those
experiences particularly childhood
developmental experiences is the shame
the
impermissible rage
the feelings of inadequacy and feelings
of being unlovable
and so we build up all these different
protection mechanisms around us to avoid
ever having to face those impermissible
wounds and those protections could be
achievement they could be they could
look good on the outside that's the
scary thing right it's a workaholism can
be really praised at times
um those it can look like alcoholism it
can look like drug addiction and we just
create all these forms of protection
around ourselves to never have to go
there but what's happened recently is in
covet and when we've been struck with
feelings of not being safe feelings
being out of control a lot of our
typical coping mechanisms won't work
anymore what are typical coping
mechanisms for most people typical
coping mechanisms
heading to the fridge overeating uh
overworking not working like numbing out
vegging out the sofa uh A coping
mechanism and I refer to coping
mechanisms as protector Parts I am now
trained in internal family systems
therapy and so in ifs we talk about
these protectors and what are they
protecting us from those exiled child
Parts those impermissible parts that we
don't want to ever touch don't want to
go protectors are the
um
copy mechanisms they're addictive or
non-healthy coping mechanisms let me
hear you say yes so-called protectors
totally exactly we don't want to go and
face the pain and sometimes we don't
even know that they're a problem like
like a workaholic may not may not yet
know that that's a problem for them or
uh codependency so they're constantly
protecting themselves by finding
relationship or there's for me there was
the controller you you were you were in
studio with the controller many times
and and you also even went as far as
like almost pick up on that at early in
our relationship where you're like you
know it could be a little easier you
would you noticed it for me and there's
there's and I have one that's called
knives out she's not out anymore but she
she was like this like you know like if
you with me
I'm done so were those your two main
coping mechanisms I guess well well
there was like 25 year old cocaine
addict and then there was the
um you know another interesting
protector part is even spirituality at
times because
while it's a beautiful practice to be on
a spiritual Quest and it's what I've
been writing about for over a decade we
we can at times use our spiritual
practice to get above the pain
and so for example uh your newly sober
and you're like in every meditation
class and you're doing you know your
Kundalini Yoga and you know you're
you're just you're getting high on your
own Supply right which is excellent it's
much better than drinking and there's
and it's a beautiful Pursuit
but it's also another form of protecting
what is deeper and frankly that
spiritual bypassing as we would call it
is actually a tremendous gift at times
because it's too painful to go to those
places so if spirituality is what you've
got that's way better than the drugs and
the alcohol right but it's still masking
but it's still another way of masking
it's still another way of getting above
what is so uncomfortable to face below
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet design specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
a link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number four is live an
intense and profound life with sad Guru
guruji my question is
how does one deal with insecurities
how does one deal with insecurity
life is insecure
there is no security about life because
shall I reveal a secret to you
hmm
however young and healthy you are you're
going to die one day
I'll bless you with a long life but you
will die one day is it okay
no
so you can die joyfully or you can die
crying it's up to you
but anyway you will die one day yes or
no
if you say I don't want to die today you
start the chanting I don't want to die I
don't want to die I don't want to die
all that will happen is you will not
live but you will die
yes
the fear I don't want to die will make
you not live
but it will not make you not die anyway
you will die
coming to terms with mortality is one
very important thing
if you don't come to terms with
mortality
you are living in a fancy world of
unreal world not in the real world
the real world is we come and go
so many countless number of people have
come and gone before us isn't it
you are
you're in an institution from 1857
I was just wondering how they started an
institution in that year because in that
year there was such turmoil
all over the country
19 1857.
in the country but somehow somebody
managed to start an institution
the soil that you're walking upon we
don't know how many people about it
yes or no
all these countless people number of
people who walk this planet before you
and me where are they they're all
topsoil
yes or no
this will also become top soil one day
unless your friends
choose to bury you real deep
fearing you may raise from the dead
and there have there have been certain
instances
this happened
there was an old couple in Texas
over 75 years of age
it was their dream to go to the holy
land or the Jerusalem
but because of business and then
children children growing up going to
the university and their marriages and
da da
they never made it
when they're over 75 years of age they
made the trip to Jerusalem
Jerusalem is a place
where every Cobblestone reeks of History
so they walked that pathway where Jesus
is supposed to have walked they went to
that place where he's supposed to have
walked on the water and many things like
this
they were overwhelmed by this whole
experience and unfortunately the lady
had a heart attack and she died
then the man was preparing to take her
body back to Texas
but then the local people approached and
said see
Jerusalem is the holy land this is the
right place to die
she's done the right thing
so let's do all the rituals here and
bury her here
and it just costs you
twenty five thousand dollars
because
if you take her back
to Texas just the transportation costs
eighteen thousand dollars
and local charges and in America the
cemetery charges are very heavy all this
put together you will spend much more
money and above all she has chosen to
die in the Holy Land This is where she
must be buried let's do it
the man said no I am taking her back to
Texas
they said see you're very distressed
because of your wife's death you're not
able to think straight we can understand
so we will give you a super discount
fifteen thousand dollars
this are hiding place you know
let's do it
the man thought about it and he said no
I will take her back to Texas
then they said see it doesn't make sense
you I can see you're very distressed
you've lost your wife of 45 years so
obviously you're very very distressed
you're not thinking straight at all we
can understand this just because of that
you are an American and you are from
Texas so we give you an absolute super
super discount ten thousand dollars
Let's Do It come on let's do it let's do
it
you must what I am talking if you want
to understand you must go to Kashi
someplace how these things happen you
know
then the man thought about it and he
said no I'm taking her back to Texas
and they threw their hands up and said
why what's the problem with you
ten thousand dollars let's do it
he said see
in Texas dead stay dead
[Laughter]
so
if you come to terms with your mortality
security insecurity all these things
will go
you are living on a daily basis as if
you are forever
the fundamental awareness that this is
motto this is here only for a limited
amount of time if this was a you know a
normal conscious thing for you
you would put your life to best use
for sure
and
if you come to terms with that one thing
there will be no insecurity because
there is nothing to gain nothing to lose
in this life
you came with nothing whatever the hell
is happening you're on the prophet side
yes or no
isn't it so did you come with investment
no you come with nothing
so whatever the hell is happening you're
always on the profit side isn't it and
anyway they don't allow you to take a
container
in the end
so all you have is how profound intense
and beautiful is your experience of life
so don't make too much fuss about it
you're acting as if you're going to lose
something
no there's nothing to lose nothing to
gain because
you come and you go you may think oh my
life my life no it's your your life on
this planet is like a pop-up on the
computer screen you've seen this pop-ups
you just pop up and pop out
in the meantime will you rise and shine
is the only question
all right
so if anywhere you shine sometimes you
may be seen by people sometimes you may
not be seen by people the important is
you sh you're shining within yourself
and that's all that matters if people
have eyes they will see it if they have
no eyes they won't see it that's their
problem
but
you are living an intense and profound
life that's all that matters here if you
understand this and if you bring this
into your life
insecurity will not happen because
security can happen only in death
that's all
people keep asking me coming to me and
asking me sadhguru please bless us
nothing should happen to us I say hey
what kind of blessing is this
my blessing is let everything happen to
you
everything that's life must happen to
you have you come here to avoid life or
have you come here to experience life
please you must make a decision right
now have you come here to avoid life or
to experience life
experience life all the different
dimensions of what this life holds must
happen to you isn't it so
if you come to avoid life
there's an ocean right here
you can jump into the ocean
see if you want to avoid life
you must die
it's a more efficient way of doing
things isn't it you're alive when you
try to avoid life you'll become
miserable
if you feel insecure that's what you
will do you will try to avoid life when
you're alive and try to avoid life it'll
cause immense misery
when you're alive you live
when you die you die don't get up from
the dead rule number five is know your
values and vision with Lewis house can
you run me through then because I know
there's gonna be people that people
listening to this that just had we both
done this exercise and it was amazing
and they're gonna they're now thinking
what is the values part what is the
vision problem what's the lifestyle part
yeah I think the values is really about
well for me the values is like okay I
Value Health in my life I'm I'm going to
be focused on my health I value my
mission my team my business like that's
a conscious Mission I value spending
time with friends I value all my hobbies
and activities that's salsa dancing
that's traveling that's all these
different things I enjoy doing I value
conscious conversations
like I want to have conscious
conversations I can't have superficial
conversations I literally met someone
this morning before I came here
um who is a part of a big company here
in London and within two minutes I'd
probably like shouldn't do this but I
don't know if all British people are
this way and it's not a bad thing but
it's very good with like surface talk
you know oh how's it how's the flight
and uh let's order some tea and crumpets
or whatever it is you know and it's like
which is fine but I just can't handle it
after a few minutes so right away I I'm
the person sitting next to me I was like
how's your marriage you know I just
asked I was just like how long you've
been married for you know and she was
like I've been married for like six
years and I go
what's three questions you wish you
would have asked I literally did this I
go what's three questions you wish you
would have asked the day before you got
married that you didn't ask because I'm
just fascinated by people you know I'm
curious I'm like how amazing has the
marriage been how has it been has it
been healthy have you had challenges is
there anything you wish you would have
changed or talked about sooner
and right away she's like opening up and
like being vulnerable and I was like
sorry to put this on you right now but
I'm just fascinated because I want to
learn from everyone and um
so I was like I want to have conscious
conversations it's one of my values so
we have these deep intimate talks all
the time
and so I write down a list of all my
values the vision is this is the vision
from my personal life so personally I
want to be working out I'm going to be
healthy as an individual my vision is my
my mission which is building a conscious
business to serve millions of people to
help them improve the quality of their
life and I this is a major priority to
me this is my one and two priority this
is my vision and also our relationship
Vision which I think is extremely
important to talk about with your
partner
here's a vision I have for our
relationship for these
these couple years and for the future
this is what I see with flexibility
nothing's set in stone but this is what
I see what is your vision for our
relationship because maybe her or his
vision is different
one person wants to have kids the other
person doesn't one wants to get married
the other doesn't one wants an open
relationship the other one doesn't want
that one wants their family around every
weekend the other one's like I don't
want to be around your family every
weekend so what is the vision of our
shared relationship
and then lifestyle I love you know
traveling do you like to travel I love
to watch these types of movies I like to
eat these types of foods I like these
types of experiences this is a lifestyle
that I live if you have a completely
different lifestyle that's going to be
hard for us if you like to do none of
those things if you like to stay at home
every day where I want to go out and
network with people and travel
that's just going to be a talk we're
going to be butting heads a lot and
there might be maybe it works but it
might cause some friction and distance
in the future so are we in alignment of
values vision and lifestyle it doesn't
have to be 100 perfect but is there
alignment in each category and I think
the more alignment you have
the more potential for a better
healthier relationship and rule number
six the last one before some very
special bonus Clips is do what's good
for you with Gary vaynerchuk I've got
some weird elements that people can't
run my playbook but I couldn't write run
other people's Playbook so pay attention
find what works for you try try it
multiple times Steve said something you
like try it once didn't work Steve's not
an idiot you don't suck try it again on
this the very Crux of all of this is
that key point which is about
self-awareness and as I realized that in
my late 20s that self-awareness was
really the key to
um to most things in life and I remember
writing a quote my Instagram which is
still my favorite quote of all time
where I said
um
there's no self-development there's no
self-development without self-awareness
you can read as many books as you like
100 but if you can't read yourself
you'll never learn a thing it's why I've
never read a book yeah exactly so right
like to me the only thing I've read is
my feelings so how does how does one
person listening to this now that's been
listening to our content and you know
they really want to be a an entrepreneur
they want to have a big Media Company
whatever it might be
but they don't know they don't have them
like objectively they don't have
Minerals Well how do they go about
discovering they don't have the minerals
by going in the pool and drowning okay
you know it's not for you and I to judge
because we've been wrong too much yeah
I've been wrong so much it scares the
out of me and I'm gifted with
intuition that when I'm dead I hope they
can test for it because I think I'm all
time and I've been wrong a ton that
makes me believe everyone's wrong
so if you're listening here's a couple
things that are good call out that may
bring value instead of what I just said
asking what you're in it for is
humongous
yeah but this generation I don't think
they know because people don't know this
first of all you're part of this
generation yeah
that's how I know but you know but I
know too but guess what my generation
this I'm so done with this my generation
didn't know either guess what when I was
22 all my friends wanted to hook up too
all my friends wanted a BMW too and by
the way as somebody who observed people
his whole life the people that were
older me the people that were buying
expensive wine for me when I was 20 and
they were 35 they everybody wants stuff
to communicate to others that they're
winning we've been putting on makeup
since we have clubs hitting each other
like it's what humans do we do things to
communicate
yes why to hide we're hiding
we we used to do it with status right
now we've decided on each other our
current move to hide is by tearing each
other down that status too I want to be
more I want to be the most leftist I
want to be the most on the right I want
you know the problem is unlike buying a
BMW and going into debt when you're
doing this one you're hurting other
people's feelings um
it's one thing when you're hurting your
credit score it's another thing when
you're trying to make someone feel bad
about themselves that's why the acts of
us collectively at 8 billion people
right now is completely and utterly
unacceptable which is why I'm
desperately communicating at the highest
levels about the stuff that I want to
put into the world as a counter to
people's us against them girls versus
boys blacks versus Jews Republicans it's
exhausting
like once people understand there's one
team humans let's let's you can be mad
at elephants you can be mad at Falcons
but like being mad at each other is the
most counterproductive thing and we need
to go into tribes my country my sports
team I understand this because I hate
all the other football teams it's the
only place I get those feelings the way
people feel about Republicans and
Democrats or genders and races or
countries the only place I can touch on
it emotionally is American football my
level of actual disdain towards Patriot
fans is real I feel the rage
the fact that I do that for something
silly that's a form of escapism that's a
couple hours a week to like reset and
like enjoy and Escape like people watch
movies or ski or exercise that's silly
that's football that's silly we're doing
this in real life to each other
and it's it's got to stop and I think
it's it starts with people understanding
if you are on others right now
it's a complete reflection to your own
unhappiness and insecurity I had a kid
come up to me and this is why I was
asking the question is after I did a
tool can he said to me as I knelt down
on stage he said I want to he must have
been 18. I want to be a public speaker
too and I'm like why
why is always the right answer and the
answer you'll get from this generation
this my generation is well I wanna I
wanna change the world Gary yeah of
course and then you go what do you want
to change about it they go I in fact
what I came to learn is they want to be
the type of person that's known for
changing the World Language admiration
that's right they saw the audience class
right and they want that feeling the
money the fame the accolades the blue
check the followers the fun I understand
it's the problem with all the things I
just mentioned is they're a
vulnerability to your own happiness if
it's not balanced there's not by the way
sometimes people get mad at me in the
other direction like Gary I worked my
face off I can buy a watch or a car I'm
like of course you can the why
if you like love this like I don't
understand sports cars and the feeling
of going that fast that's not me but I
understand buying rare sports cards and
that's enjoyable if you enjoy that
that's phenomenal when I talk about
materialistic things I talk about makeup
for insecurity if you are burning the
midnight oil you know how people burn
out they're working till two in the
morning to buy the expensive car to use
it to close their insecurity to get the
affirmation from the opposite sex or
their friends that's that that system's
broke it won't work I I mean I don't
know what to tell you like everyone's
like okay Gary but I'd rather have the
money like this whole like I'd rather
cry in my Ferrari than drive a Toyota or
take the bus you say that
do you really want to be in a mental
place where you're on the borderline of
suicide and you have heavy drug usage
even though you make three million
dollars a year 17 million dollars a year
because you know this now Steve you've
worked very hard and you have the
talents and the luck of the draw and you
put in the execution to now run in
circles where you know what I'm about to
say is ungodly true which is the
following an extraordinary amount of
people that have unlimited resources are
desperately lonely insecure unhappy and
borderline depression suicidal that's
just truth
the Dallas Uber driver
so as somebody who has gotten into
countless Ubers and some small
percentage of them know who I am and
then of course they start asking
questions
talk to me about chasing your dreams and
this quote that you have that an aha
moment does not necessarily lead to an
aha life
yeah the Uber driver in Dallas that's in
this book
um I get choked up when I think about
him uh an aha I choked up I get choked
up because
what happens for me every single day
is and you hear from people every single
day you've got millions and millions of
people that are inspired by empowered by
impacted by your content there are
people out there that use your work as a
lifeline
and it is humbling
and what I am
really present to in the work that I'm
putting out and the stuff that I'm
sharing whether it's my failures or the
things that I'm using that are helping
me in my own struggles
is just how much people are holding
themselves back and how much pain people
feel
because most folks know what they dream
about
and what they want
and yet
they're spending all of their time and
energy arguing against what they want
and so you can have all these epiphanies
I hope that when somebody listens to our
conversation and watches this that they
have a massive aha moment but it's not
going to mean
if you don't take action and do
something about it
the aha moment is the door that opens
but your new life does not begin unless
you step through the door
and most people and that's what was
so kind of
you know the simple idea of high-fiving
yourself of encouraging yourself of
supporting yourself most people when you
have an aha moment and the door to your
new life opens up
instead of going I got this let's go and
high-fiving yourself to step forward
most of us go I don't know if I'm worth
it I don't know if right now is the
right time to do this I don't think I'm
good enough I failed so many times I
can't go through that door
and that's the problem I want to attack
right now that there is somewhere in
your life that you know what you want
you can feel it pulling you and you are
actively arguing against it you're
bringing yourself down you're beating
yourself out like people will cheer for
you and me they won't cheer for
themselves
I'm the same way and so this Uber driver
the story that you're talking about I
get into the car and we start driving
and I'm on the phone as we're driving
and I'm having a conversation with
somebody about this daytime talk show
that I launched which was a dream with
Sony Pictures Television and then uh was
promptly fired after season one it was a
huge failure because we didn't make it
to season two
huge failure in real world terms massive
success when it comes to the timeline of
my life and so I'm talking to this
person about the talk show I hang up the
phone and this Uber driver comes alive
he's like oh my gosh I can't believe
you're in my cab and I'm like why and he
says because I I want to talk to you
about something I think you can help me
and I'm like great how can I help you
and he says I have a dream of being a
oscar-winning uh actor and creating
opportunities for other black and Latino
men to do the same in acting and I'm
like freaking fantastic what the
are you doing in Dallas right yeah the
guy's 25 and so I I go you know the game
is in New York and L.A I mean sure you
can act you can write stuff you can be
here in Dallas but why are you not in La
why are you not in New York and he's
like you're right you're right you're
right I need to move to LA like why not
and he says I have 700 in my bank
account I'm like that's freaking
fantastic you have 700 in a car dude
drop me off and get driving what are you
waiting for and so we have this whole
conversation and I write about it in
this book where I am actively arguing
for his dream and he is actively arguing
against his dream
and what is so sad is throughout this
conversation Tom he's like you're right
700 could get me there you're right I am
only 25. you're right if I keep thinking
and thinking and thinking and thinking
about what I want to be doing I'm not
only going to drive in circles my whole
life is going to spin in circles as I
think about what I want and I don't do
about it and then you are going to
find yourself not at 25 but at 45 or 65
and you're going to be so filled with
regret that you never put a put a bet on
yourself
and so this conversation ends with him
declaring that he's going to go to
California and me giving him a bunch of
tools that I talk about in this book
and the point of the story is does he
move or not I don't know
the point of the story is it's so easy
to see what somebody else should do it's
so easy to cheer for somebody else we
all do that right we cheer for our
favorite sports teams we follow our
favorite influencers and authors we plan
birthday parties for our friends we take
on extra work from our colleagues we
support everyone around us we do not
know how to do it for ourselves I know
you all have big goals Big Dreams big
aspirations just like I do you've got
Ambitions to become an amazing person to
build your career to create contribute
to give to be an awesome human being but
all of that is impossible without great
habits set up if you don't have routine
and structure set up in a way that will
keep you on track then you'll you'll
fall off and and having new goals
without new habits is kind of like you
know having a new car without wheels you
know the habits are the wheels they're
the things that make you able to achieve
the goals so you got to have good habits
but the challenge for most people isn't
that knowledge I mean you know you need
to have good habits it's you can't keep
the Habit going right have you ever
started it the new year you're going to
get healthier and you start that habit
of working out more on a more regular
basis and then it goes away or you say
you know I'm going to be more kind and
more patient and more awesome to my
partner my lover and you start being
nice for two or three days and then on
the fourth day you're a jerk you know
and you're like why what happened I said
I was gonna be nicer it's that you
didn't set up the most important thing
you needed to maintain a habit so what's
the biggest secret I've learned in
almost 20 years in this field it's so
simple but most people don't have it
it's called trigger moments
you have to set up trigger moments to
activate your habits what do I mean by
that well let's say you want to become a
better person you know you want to
become more kind more patient more
loving with people now you can just set
that intention or write that down in
your vision in your journal or set up on
a vision board that you look at once in
a while but in day-to-day life it's not
enough you need things to trigger you to
remind you to be that particular kind of
person right it's almost like if you
could have a little angel speaking in
your ear all day long to tell you what
to do and how to be you'd obviously
become better well that makes sense well
let's use that idea let's use that idea
by setting up alarms on our phones that
trigger us to do the very things we need
to do this can be so basic you're going
to laugh and then also tell you how I've
literally taught this to Fortune 50 CEOs
and they said it was the one thing that
changed their life the most dramatically
so let's start with with this let's I
have a goal in mind let's say you want
to become more present and calm
throughout the day again you could write
that down on a journal I'm going to be
more present and calm you can meditate
in the mornings like today don't be more
present and calm and you're you could
you could start out with good intentions
but those fall apart without a trigger
moment set up throughout the day to
remind you that so what if you did this
what if you just set up on your phone
three alarms during the day with a label
that said
close your eyes
take 10 deep breaths in remind yourself
to be calm
so let's say you're going through your
day it's crazy right it's 10 a.m and
also Bing your phone goes off you look
down and it says close your eyes take 10
deep breaths and then again it happens
at two o'clock and again it happens at 6
pm and again it happens at 8pm what's
gonna happen you always look at your
phone don't you it's going to go
throughout the day you're going to
forget and the funniest thing is I've
had so many people do this worldwide
we're talking about hundreds of
thousands of people I've taught to do
this hundreds of thousands and they tell
me all the time that changed everything
and you'll think once you set it up that
the next day you you'll you'll forget
about it no that alarm will go off you
forgot you set the dang alarm there it
goes off in your face you're like all
right I'm trying to be calmer and more
present close my eyes take 10 deep
breaths re-ground myself here we go
it you can't do it once a day you have
to have moments throughout the day that
trigger you to enact the new Behavior I
know this makes sense to you but it's a
challenge for a lot of people because
they never set those things up so what
if you did it with an alarm
so for example for me on the opposite
Spectrum I don't want to just be calmer
and more present I Want More Energy
throughout the day so here's what I do
one of my big trigger moments is every
time my butt hits a chair I don't care
if I'm on a plane or I was like where
we're shooting here I I wrote a lot of
my books here I wrote the motivation
Manifesto here I wrote The Charge here
and if I'm going to write my butt hits
the chair I grab my phone I open the
timer and I set 50 minutes
now at 50 minutes the timer goes it
starts buzzing and I look at that and I
go oh that's my trigger to get energy so
I stand up I go get some water I take a
glass of water drink it down I do some
stretches and I do some exercise just
really briefly or I'll go for a walk
whatever it is but I'll do something
that usually takes just two to five
minutes then I'll sit back down I'll set
that 50 minute alarm and I'll work
and what that does is every 50 minutes
it triggers me to change how I'm
physically moving it changes my
attention so that throughout the day I'm
continually refreshed so I never have
that two three four o'clock time where
I'm like ah you know why because I've
triggered my day so that my energy is
maintained throughout the day makes
sense right at least could be as simple
as let's say you want to be healthier in
your life okay let's set up some trigger
moments for you in this way let's say
every time you drop off the kids on the
way back to the house you stop at the
grocery store and get some fresh produce
that's just a trigger it's like okay did
one thing drop kids off now tied to that
triggered from that action drop kids off
is go to health food store or let's say
you want to get healthier in the morning
one of the easiest ways to help people
maintain a better exercise program is
this
set a trigger you wake up in the morning
your first action is to drink water
put your exercise shoes on it might get
dressed if you were naked just saying so
you get dressed put your shoes on you go
downstairs or you go to the gym and
that's the trigger you woke up you do
these actions nothing interrupts those
actions that's the action and you have
to have those set up one of my other
favorite trigger moments to set up is
door frame triggers what do you remember
that when you walk into a new room
to have a psychological trigger go off
in your mind that you've associated with
that door frame so let me give you an
example if I walk into my house at night
after if I've been working all day and
I'm going to walk in I'm gonna see my
lady I have it so when I ever walk
through the doors of my house three
words repeat off immediately in my mind
because I've done it so many times
consciously I went to the door I said
the three words said three words said
the three words and I did this so many
times and now when I walk through a door
my mind automatically triggers those
three words and I remember to be those
three words so what words would you love
to have describe you as a person that
you would be happy if that was how
people described you what would those
words be have those and now set them up
in your life I teach Executives to do
this as well I have them have a door
frame trigger when they walk into their
office in the morning as soon as they
walk through that door frame they have
boom three words go through their mind
about how they want to be perceived as a
leader I have them set up another door
frame every time they walk into a
meeting into the conference room when
they walk through the doors of the
conference room they have another three
words that trigger off for them and it
just reminds them how to be so these
aren't big crazy things a lot of people
that think they have to completely
change their life what would change your
life completely is setting up more
trigger moments and associations that
when you see something you do this that
when this action is taken then that
happens that when you have the
opportunity to set up alarms on your
phone you set them up so that you're
interrupted in your everyday life to
remind yourself to stick to the habits
to stick to the intention you do that
enough on a continual basis you'll find
yourself in so many ways completely
rejuvenated and I promise you'll stick
to your habits even more and once you do
that you know that everything changes if
you think that your thoughts have
something to do with your future just
from a theoretical standpoint that your
thoughts Create Your Destiny and you
think sixty to seventy thousand thoughts
in one day and ninety percent of those
thoughts are the same thoughts as the
day before well then your life isn't
going to change very much as long as
you're thinking the same way and those
those same thoughts lead to the same
choices the same choices lead to the
same behaviors the same behaviors create
the exact same experiences and we
anticipate the same feelings or emotions
from those experiences and those
emotions are the payoff that drive our
very same thoughts while our biology our
neuroscircuitry our neural chemistry our
hormones and even our Genex expression
will be equal to how we think how we act
and how we feel and how we think how we
act and how we feel is called our
personality and our personality creates
our personal reality that's it so the
present personality who's listening to
this show has created the present
personal reality called their life so if
you can latch on to this idea if you
want to create a new life a new personal
reality you got to change your
personality which means you better start
thinking about what you've been thinking
about and changing it you begin to
become conscious of your unconscious
actions or habits or behaviors and
modify them
and then we have to begin to look at the
emotions that we live by every single
day
that'll keep us connected to the past
and decide do these emotions belong in
our future so most people are trying to
create a new personal reality as the
same personality and it doesn't work you
literally have to become someone else so
the principle of Neuroscience says that
nerve cells that fire together wire
together you keep thinking the same way
making the same choices demonstrating
the same habits creating the same
experiences that stamp the same networks
of neurons into the same patterns all
for the familiar feeling called you and
you do that for 10 years on end you're
going to begin to hardwire certain
patterns in your brain that becomes your
identity and by the time we're 35 years
old it kind of becomes fixed right and
psychology used to say that you can't
change that but we now know that you can
so then that kind of box in the brain
that is the habit of ourselves it's a
we're 95 percent of the time running a
series of programs so then sitting and
doing the work had we have to become
disentangled from those programs and so
the moment you decide to do something
differently or make a new Choice what
most people don't want to face is that
discomfort and that that discomfort that
that uncertainty that lack of
predictability the that that that
unknown is what people are afraid of
because they'd rather live in guilt at
least they can predict who they're going
to be then take a chance in possibility
so when a person begins to understand
this and you say well
how long have you been this way and they
say I've been like this for 35 years and
you say why 35 years because 35 years
ago I had this one event well the
stronger the emotion you feel from
reaction from that event the more
altered you feel inside of you the more
the brain Narrows its focus and freezes
the image and takes a snapshot and
that's called a memory right so then
forget the memory just overcome the
emotion because it's the emotion that
keeps you anchored to the past so that
sounds really good theoretically
but when you step out into that unknown
into that void
the body really is in a habit and what a
habit is when the body becomes the mind
or if you're thinking about that past
event and it's producing an emotion well
you need an image and a feeling to start
the conditioning process so the body's
either conditioned into the familiar
past or it's hardwired in the
predictable future because it wakes up
every single day and runs through the
same series of routine actions so the
present moment then becomes the unknown
when people start feeling that
discomfort today they'd rather get on
their cell phone and call someone or get
up and say I can't meditate or you know
I have too much to do they excuse
themselves they return back into that
familiar feeling because the body's
actually telling the brain The Habit is
when the body becomes the mind so the
body stepping out into the unknown and
says ooh I'd rather feel guilty I'd
rather feel unhappy than be in this this
conference so then at least then when
they return back to that familiar
feeling then they feel safe so they step
out in the unknown and the body starts
influencing the mind saying you can
start tomorrow you're too busy it's your
mother's fault you know it's your
culture's fault I don't have enough
money this isn't going to work
those are the programs in there that are
standing in the way between you and your
future so then nerve cells that no
longer fire together no longer wire
together so the act of observing those
states of Mind and Body
means you're no longer the program
you're the Consciousness observing that
program so so then
to meditate it means to become familiar
with so as you become familiar with
those thoughts you become conscious of
how you speak you become aware of how
you act you notice how you're feeling
the more conscious you become of those
unconscious programs the less
unconscious you'll go in your waking day
why because it's not enough to just have
a great meditation and get up and get on
the freeway and get in traffic and
getting stressed you just return back to
the old self again our job then
is to sustain that modified State of
Mind and Body the entire day and if you
can get ready because something
different or unusual is going to begin
to happen in your life and it will come
as a coincidence or synchronicity and
that's breadcrumbs from the Divine
saying you're on the path just keep
doing it there'll be another one just
keep staying in that energy and so
teaching people then to understand that
there's a formula that we now know that
if you apply that formula you'll begin
to see those changes and now as people
are doing it more and more
effectively the results are going up as
well we just had Bond University they
just took a whole bunch of my brain
scans from 10 years ago
huge clinical study a lot of analysis
and and they're Blown Away by the speed
in which
the community can change brain or heart
coherence they they know how to do it
it's not
something that's that's separate from
them they've practiced it enough times
that they they now know how to do it so
what's the significance of that well
really simple
in your life if you start returning back
to the same reactions to the same people
and circumstances you're returning back
to the old self so you got to stay
conscious in your life and and if you're
not being defined by a vision of the
future then you're left with the
memories of the past and you will be
predictable in your life so Crossing
that River of change from the old self
to the new self there's a neurological
biological chemical hormonal a genetic
death of the old self but if you teach
people there's something on the other
side they won't give up on themselves
they'll keep going so there's enough
evidence to encourage people and you
can't tell me you're too old to do this
work you can't tell me you're too sick
to do this work you can't tell me you
had a turbulent past or or that you're
too overweight or too underweight or too
out of shape or you can't even tell me
that you've never meditated before in
fact some of our greatest
scans or people who just have never
meditated before that are trying to do
anything they just follow instructions
so
our community now is beginning to
understand that it is possible and they
go all in not 50 and not sixty percent
and when we do a week-long event we got
a thousand people or 1500 people and
they are all in and that when they start
getting Beyond themselves that first day
or second day once they start getting
Beyond themselves and that magic starts
to happen then I have no idea I can't
predict what's going to happen next and
it's usually pretty pretty exciting you
need that instinct for meaning too so
and we should get this real straight why
do you need it well you need it because
life is really really difficult right I
mean people have a rough time of it
there's plenty of suffering in life and
everyone is going to encounter it right
there you don't you know you learn this
as a clinical psychologist and you know
this generally you know unless you're an
extraordinarily fortunate person
um you don't have to talk to someone for
very long and and really talk to them
and get beneath the surface until you
find you know there's a tragedy or two
or three or ten lurking not very far
beneath the surface someone in the
family is very ill there's a childhood
history of extreme pathology alcoholism
somewhere in the family maybe a touch of
insanity someone has cancer you know
someone someone older relative is dying
there's financial trouble there's
economic trouble there's marital trouble
it's like life is trouble and now you
know that doesn't mean it's all trouble
but man it's trouble and sometimes it's
it's a lot of trouble and sometimes it's
so much trouble that you can you can
barely stand it and and you see that
because people you know people get
depressed and they commit suicide and
the reason they do that is because they
think not being is better than being and
that's quite the decision you know so
and and it's not that uncommon among
people who are depressed and so it's
it's a it's a very it's a very important
thing to consider and it and it isn't
just a matter of depression and suicide
that's bad enough but you know if you're
unhappy because your suffering has
pushed you past the point of your
ability to cope then there's all sorts
of other things that can happen to you
that aren't directed towards you you can
become cynical and you can become bitter
and you can become cruel and you can
become narcissistic and deceitful and
arrogant and and it's like everything's
for you and then you're out for Revenge
that's a nice one I don't know against
who but maybe everyone maybe even
including you because you're not happy
about the rule you've played in
generating your own misery I mean
there's a lot of Darkness underneath the
suffering and so and and that's that's
an ever-present existential danger for
human beings you know we're aware of the
future we're aware of our fragility
we're aware of our mortality it's
something that makes us truly unique
truly conscious in a way that no other
creature is and capable of things that
no other creature can do but also
bearing an unbelievably heavy
existential load were the only creatures
that have to always contend with the
fact that we're finite and that everyone
we know is in the same position that
allied with the suffering and so that's
there all the time and and you know even
even in in the brightest moments in some
sense you know in in Renaissance
paintings in still lifes they used to
put a Memento momento Mori often in the
in the still life like a skull somewhere
in the corner or sometimes sometimes in
in a very strange perspective so that
you could only see this skull if you
were standing like right beside the
painting instead of dead on but the idea
was to always remember you know that
everything that exists is Tainted or
touched with the with the with the with
it with the taint of mortality and you
know that's rough but there's some
useful things in it it keeps you awake
and it keeps you focused if you're
careful but it also does indicate to you
if you think about it the necessity of
having a meaning in your life because
because
if it's true intrinsically that life has
this unbearable element of suffering
which seems to be completely in in what
would you say indisputable as far as I'm
concerned and it's worse than that too
because it's not just suffering it's
suffering contaminated with malevolence
right it's it's bad enough to have
something bad happen to you and it's
likely that that'll happen but it's even
worse for you to do it to yourself and
to know that you did it that's rough and
it's also extraordinarily rough to be
betrayed by someone else or you know
tyrannized by your own culture and so
and that's that's not just suffering
that's like unnecessary and pointless
suffering that's been directed at you by
something that wants that to happen and
so both of those are very very powerful
let's say archetypal forces suffering
and malevolence and we have to deal with
them at every level of reality and you
need something to you need something to
push back against that it's not optional
if that's the D default position and I
think it's the default position like a
meaningless life isn't meaningless
it's suffering and malevolence
that's not good and and if that's acted
out you know that that's the other thing
if that's acted out and I've read the
accounts and the actions of people
who've
taken a very vicious turn into the
darkest parts of the underworld
consequence of their resentment and
their malevolence and then their desire
to make everything in the world suffer
for the outrage of its existence man I
mean that's how we turn things into hell
if you want to know why totalitarian
States take the brutal twists they take
and why people are motivated to do the
absolutely terrible things that they do
well that's why is that the suffering
and the malevolence that's intrinsic to
life overwhelms them and and they turn
and they turn in a very bad Direction
and then they make everything that's
already bad way worse and we're very
very inventive at such things and so
that's not good unless that's the path
you want that's a bad idea you need an
alternative and that's meaning think big
act small think big have a big goal Big
Dreams big desires big mission big big
Vision you're going to change the world
think big let's go we love that as
entrepreneurs right let's think big and
change change the world and act small
in that you got to do something
because the only thing you're missing is
momentum
where what most people do is if you're
just thinking big and feel like you have
to act big from the start
then nothing ever ends up happening and
that big goal dies within you
we are afraid of taking the first step
we are afraid of building momentum we
are afraid of people seeing us and
nobody's seen us I just finished this
seven day challenge
and built to serve helping people become
thought leaders and people are afraid of
people watching their content and what
their what those people are going to say
and they're equally afraid of nobody
watching their content so you're afraid
of somebody seeing what you're doing and
judging you and you're also afraid of
people not seeing what you're doing and
you're creating an obscurity so you're
afraid of being seen and not being seen
at the exact same time is it any wonder
why you're not creating is there any
wonder why you're not making is there
any wonder why you're stuck and just
planning and strategizing and making the
the perfect thing happen before
something ever happens is it ever any
wonder why if you want to start a
YouTube channel you're still stuck on
what the opening sentence is going to be
and what microphone you're going to use
and what camera and what lighting and
what the background and how your hair is
going to look and your wardrobe and is
there any wonder why you're still stuck
on that instead of just creating
because we're afraid we're afraid of
being seen and we're afraid of not being
seen at the same time and so we've
convinced ourselves why we can't do
something with with you know rational
logical reasons that we believe
are really you're just not making
content you're just not making progress
you're just not having the conversations
you need to have you're just not
building the business that you should be
building right whatever the thing is
it's just at the end of the day it's
just fear
and the thing that's missing is momentum
how I encourage people to get through it
is what I tell myself I expect to suck
at the beginning
whatever you do
when it's your first time expect to suck
right just expect to suck at the start
why do you think you're going to be
amazing the first time you go and create
something you're not it's gonna suck
it's it's not gonna be very good like
even objectively it's not gonna be very
good probably
but that's okay doesn't mean you suck as
a person
I think it's amazing I think the fact
that you're willing to try is an
inspiration and so whenever you're first
getting started off when you have
expectations and you don't meet those
expectations in this Gap this is the gap
that prevents you from taking further
action
how many times have you tried to do
something you got started you weren't
getting results like you thought you
would and you just quit right away how
many times have you recorded a video
watched it back were completely
embarrassed by yourself and then never
posted it and never launched your
channel there's been people who I've
done interviews with as their first
guest on their podcast or YouTube show
or Instagram whatever and then they
never post it
they never posted because they are too
embarrassed to even launch the show and
it was it was even a decent interview
but the insecurities interferes and the
doubts creep in and so they don't they
don't post it they don't do anything
about it where you just need to expect a
suck at the beginning
just expect a suck expect it to be
terrible and that gives you the freedom
to go off and create because like
anything else whatever it is you want to
do you want to be a YouTube Creator you
want to be an entrepreneur you want to
be a coach an author a speaker whatever
it is that that your business is
it's all doable it's just a skill that
you need to learn there's there's a
bunch of skills that you need to pick up
and learn and like any other skill you
can learn it of course you can learn it
you can pick up any skill
but you don't have the skill right now
and so don't overly judge yourself for
not having the skill and not being good
enough as a human being just because you
don't have the skill set yet
right this isn't you're not good enough
as a human it's you're not good enough
at this specific skill set yet that when
you can figure that thing out and get
the trading education experience then
you can go and accomplish the goal of
course
but we overly judge ourselves and then
we don't build momentum
one of my movie makers
uh his name is Michael he's an amazing
human he
wanted to start making content want to
start making videos wanted to start
doing interviews and he was he was
afraid of asking people to be on the
show and him being the interview were he
was fine being an interviewee when
people were asking him questions but he
didn't want to be the interviewer and
was afraid to ask people questions and
so we had a discussion and we came up
with a concept where it was
um his show called his show is called
empowering conversations with a disabled
man so he's disabled he wants to help
reduce the stigma around people with
disabilities he wants to have open
conversations he wants to help people
who are disabled find Hope and
inspiration and power and he also wants
to
educate able-bodied people to how to how
to help support cherish their disabled
friends or the community and so we came
up with a concept of empowering
conversations with a disabled man and he
launched his first live interview where
he was having the conversation he had a
guest come on and he was doing the
interview and it was the idea to action
that made all the difference because
he'd been thinking about doing a show
and thinking about making content and
you know being too afraid and being
stuck in his head like all of us do
myself included all of us do
and to his credit the thing that that
I did not do at his stage in this career
was he just went off and did it he just
okay you know what here's an idea I'm
gonna do something about it I'm gonna do
something about it I'm gonna get started
and he had his first one I asked him how
he did he said it was so much fun it was
so great it was so amazing and now he
scheduled the second one he's gonna keep
doing more it's a great win and that it
worked out now if he keeps going on this
show you know say he does 100 episodes
of the show he's gonna look back on his
first video and realize oh my gosh I was
so bad at the beginning right but look
at the journey look at the growth
same thing for you whatever you're
starting off doing and just expect to
suck at the beginning expect to suck
expect no results expect nobody to see
it expected to be terrible and tomorrow
you're going to keep going you can make
it a little bit better and a little bit
better and a little bit better and when
you look back on 10 days 20 days 50 days
100 days you'll come back and say holy
cow I'm really getting better why
because you developed a skill you were
you were still the same awesome human
now you're developing the skill set to
actually get better at the thing that
you want to do makes all the difference
the only thing you're missing is
momentum so just repeat yourself repeat
to yourself
the only thing I'm missing is momentum
the only thing you're missing is
momentum you've got the heart the care
the passion the desire to serve the
vision the just the soul to help you've
got all that you know you can help
oh you're missing is momentum
just not doing enough and that's not
that's not a beat down to say judge
yourself and you suck again as a person
and you should be doing more don't do
that
but take the time that you spend
criticizing yourself and judging
yourself for not being good enough and
use that energy to then just go make
something and expect to suck so a couple
things that help me that that that gives
me the permission to
to start so it's not a high bar it's a
it's there is no bar
there is the bar is solo that there is
no bar and that gives you permission to
just start and to create the momentum
you're looking for the other thing that
I find really helps me is
just trust that great ideas flow through
you
whether whether it's belief in self
whether it's belief in something higher
but just trust a good ideas flow through
you that if
an idea comes to you for something you
want to do trust it it's a good idea
trust that that is the right idea for
you that you should do it that you
should take action on it and that it's
going to serve if you're in a positive
mindset right if you're if you're in a
negative mindset then then it's good to
sleep on your ideas right if you're in a
jealous mindset or hateful mindset or
rageful mindset then the ideas that come
to you are probably not the right ideas
for you but if you're in a powering
empowering inspiring positive optimistic
mindset then the ideas that come to you
are the right ones for you and just
trust that those are the right ideas and
do something on it and shortcut your
brain because as soon as your brain
takes over it's gonna be like oh okay
but you don't know how to do this and
that and then here's another problem and
more restrictions and you you know okay
so what happens default okay let's go
default to planning and researching and
we'll keep asking questions and we'll
keep him in high and then you know next
week I'll do something and then next
week comes and you haven't done it yet
right so when an idea comes to you
find the smallest possible way to get
started on it today don't make it some
big giant thing that now you need a
million dollars in venture capital and a
huge team to accomplish
the only thing you're missing is
momentum right
so trust that great ideas flow through
you great ideas flow through you
you're here to do so much more
and take that kernel of an idea and do
something
whatever the smallest possible simplest
thing is to just build some kind of
momentum for it
to see how much did you love it how much
you want to go back and do it
without having to pressure on it having
to be the perfect thing the next big
thing the only thing that matters
because that's what keeps you stuck
slow
knowing that you're capable of more but
too afraid to act
great ideas flow through you and the
only thing you're missing is momentum
[Music]
you made it this far in a video I want
to celebrate you most people start and
don't finish most people never actually
follow through most people say they want
something but they don't ever do the
work to actually get it but you're
different you are special believe Nation
you made it here all the way to the end
and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome for Jordan
Peterson's 12 rules that will change
your life check the video right there
next to me I think you'll love it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there I was reading these these articles
on lobsters and I I
came across this this finding that
lobsters lobsters govern their postural
flexion